let's get uh to the goats in a bad way
coming out of week 11. we're usually
positive
and this is where we're a little
negative just go ahead and take the
first pick yeah we're not we're not
positive today goats in a bad way who
you got for the week that was uh
i'm gonna go with carson wentz right off
the bat i am i mean were you going to
pick him oh me
i know i thought about him too you're
right he's he's in the running but i'm
going to go with carson wentz i mean hey
really recently i think he could
probably be the top of the draft of this
every tuesday right now but you know
just the
again
the
lack of awareness the way he plays
um the way
i feel like he even carries himself
right now everything about it nothing's
good coming out of philadelphia carson
wentz whatever it is but you know the
safety in the end zone hey your left
hackle's struggling like you can't just
look blindly downfield like you got the
great wall of china blocking you they're
blocking for you no you got to be aware
that you're in the end zone and the
clock has to be different and you got to
peek at the passer edge a little bit
that play a few minutes ago i talked
about the interception you know first
and ten on the 10-yard line you know
down in the scoring area to throw a jump
ball at the four yard line denzel ward
interception
the other strip sack interception that
ended up within the pick six you know
again just not being aware of what's
around him and everything like that uh i
you know i've defended him i can't
really defend them much anymore
after the pick six that started the
scoring on sunday matt casey made the
observation that it looked like the jack
squirrick play from super bowl 18.
the raiders linebacker but at least
squyrick had to make a semi-athletic
play all the browns guy had to do was
stand there i mean the ball came right
to him it was ridiculous what a throw
that was carson wentz i think he's
probably a permanent fixture coming out
of each week of the season but but look
if you're if you're gonna get that kind
of money if you're gonna be a supposed
franchise quarterback and you're gonna
perform this way you're gonna take the
heat which leads to
tommy tommy sorry tom sorry tom you
deserve it two picks last night one for
nine throwing the ball 15 or more yards
down the field with those two
interceptions and as we discussed last
hour i think that the ego took over i
think the vanity took over i think that
on a week where we saw kyla murray and
russell wilson in prime time to start
things off patrick mahomes and derek
carr on sunday night tom brady wanted to
have a big night he wanted to show he
still got it like ralph mouth from happy
days he's still got it well maybe he
doesn't if he's going to try to do this
all the time because spraying the ball
down the field is not working
operating a more efficient offense with
two tight ends and running the football
is working because we saw it work a week
ago
they've got to get away from this now
they've got to put the ego in check and
they just have to go do what's necessary
to score more points in the opposition
so i think for what we saw on the field
the lack of fire as you pointed out and
also what may have happened in the
run-up to the game with brady imposing
his will on byron leftwich right and
bruce arians tom brady gets the goat
horns this week from me yeah i mean i i
get it you know i i really i was going
to take him first too just the way that
game looked last night the quality of
those you know interceptions everything
about it
i just felt like man we talked about it
so damn much but that's obviously got to
improve uh if they want to make a
serious move to being a contender here
all right
i'm a little torn with which way to go
here but i i think that i'm gonna have
to go with just two receivers on the
green bay packers here valdes scantling
okay and darius shepherd you know
struggling in the second half green bay
packers darius shepard 28-28 all right
man we got to get the ball back to aaron
rodgers see if he can like get back some
momentum on our side of the ball fumbled
kick return and then of course the
overtime play it's a screen pass out to
the edge valdez scandling you know after
just a big drive by the packers to go
down tie the game had a chance to maybe
win it they get the ball back and you're
going well they survived you know
probably going to go down here and at
least get a field goal
they'll get their wits together about
them here valdez scantling fumbles game
over from there uh to me you know not
that they played horrible but that was
just two
bad mistakes by solid players and big
moments that that cost the packers the
football game
yeah and like valdez can't scantling
said he's got to take the good with the
bad i mean you have to do what you can
to get past that moment because you have
to be able to perform
this weekend sunday night football
against the chicago bears but uh that
that really was a critical mistake that
contributed to the loss by green bay all
right look i i've got to go to the
saints falcons game because the falcons
had two weeks to get ready for this
and you know we're praising the saints
defense all of a sudden they're not the
1985 chicago bears but matt ryan helped
make them look like that and if if you
fancy yourself a top 10 quarterback in
the nfl
right
you've you've got to show up in these
moments yeah especially when you have
two weeks to get ready for the game two
interceptions 19 for 37 that's just
above 50 completion percentage and a
48.5
passer rating i you know i i remember
when taysom hill fumbled late in the
game i thought oh boy this opens the
door for the falcons like wait a minute
they can't even get the door there's no
change
right yeah so uh and that's got to
all come back to the quarterback you're
one of the best quarterbacks in football
franchise quarterback salary two weeks
to get ready nine points nine points are
you kidding me it's not it's not good
enough i'm sorry it's but it's it's it's
inherited in this situation yeah i i
think it's real i mean i i understand
you know you expect more with that
offense the weapons they have him at
quarterback all of that i mean the
saints seem to be all over that stuff
but yeah i know what you're saying hey
you're 30 million quarterback you know
22 million wide receiver you don't give
a damn how good the defense is you want
to see him make some plays off schedule
whatever um and yeah that that was not
the case certainly and and uh yeah you
know matt ryan his stats everything are
going to look good this year and he's
still a really damn good quarterback but
a lot of his stats are you know bullcrap
end of the game stuff too that are
misleading and i think people forget
that sometimes and we just look at it
where it is right now in the bottom line
and go oh look his stats look pretty
good he's playing good yeah but how many
of those yards and things were when the
game was competitively over and it
really didn't mean anything and the
defense was playing you know
prevent defense and all those type of
things all right my next pick i i think
i gotta go
i i hate to do this but
you know i thought about john harbaugh
with the scene he caused you know at the
start of the game and of course just the
way their team played and everything
like that
i want to i think about the bengals and
the joe burrow situation i'm mad at them
but i i guess i'm going to go with the
detroit lions the whole organization the
whole thing you know
the whole week everything
you know i mean gosh you're playing
carolina there's no teddy bridgewater
you know you've come off a game there's
a glimmer of hope to you to get in the
nfc playoff picture do all those things
and they just lay an absolute egg at in
carolina really never had a chance to
win the football game at one point they
have that trick play and you think wow
okay maybe they'll get jump started here
what you didn't even line up right how
do you not line up right on the trick
play that you probably foamed at the
mouth with all week long going well this
is going to be awesome if we run it and
you mess that up so that to me was a bad
week on the field a bad week on social
media with some other people associated
with the players on the field everything
was bad at detroit this week
i saw some people suggest yesterday that
that matt patricia was going to be fired
they play thursday you're not firing
your coach on monday when you play
thursday but but
if it happens again on thursday i won't
be surprised if there's a house cleaning
come friday for the detroit lions all
right last one for me and i thought
about
whoever threw the flag that juju smith
schuster stepped on and injured his foot
he wasn't able to practice yesterday or
he wouldn't have practiced yesterday if
they actually had a practice you know
that whole monday practice estimate
thing and then i thought wait a minute
there's a reason it's bright and yellow
so juju probably should have avoided
stepping on the flag uh so i'm gonna go
with our old friend
roddy white
because and i hate to pick two from the
same game but what the hell i'm gonna do
it it's my choice roddy white was the
tweet that he that he put up after the
saints decided to go with taysom hill
there it is saints about
to get whip trying us with taysom hill
at quarterback we about to snack them
and oh stuff like that never matters
stuff like that doesn't motivate anyone
well sean payton retweeted it minutes
after the game ended oh yes it does
matter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports